il ya une première personne ce sont des
vraies histoires inquiet bonjour baba je
travaille dans un supermarché on a une
cliente qui vient régulièrement me plais
d'ouf comment faire pour la séduire
c'est très simple c'est la technique de
la tête de gondole c'est à dire tu vas
la mener tu vas aller la voir un bien
d'autres il travaille dans un
supermarché
donc là il faut que tu te balades dans
le supermarché ll poussant des caddies à
la lime son petit caddie et là tu lui
sors de ta poche et michael owen
ont
été répétés pas du tout
alors je découvre comme ça les gars
n'ont que leur yeux d'avoir fait simple
c'est très simple sans rigoler dans un
supermarché c'est très simple vous allez
me dire ce que vous demandez et je vous
dis oui alors j'ai une technique oui
mais comme elle est alors de fait
comme elle vient régulièrement ouais
c'est qu'elle a des habitudes avec son
caddie oui vous observez bien le caddie
et la semaine d'après ou à la fréquence
soit elle revient avant qu'elle vienne
voulu remplissez son caddie et quant à
l'arrivée vous dites madame regarder
votre casier là il ya cinq ans vous
plus aussi qu'il a fait ça madame aussi
vous gardez appelé directement le 17
[Applaudissements]
oh
cette simple fois être beaucoup plus un
poil oui elle est d'aller dans les
rayons faut la voir et puis lui demander
est ce que je peux vous aider vous avez
vous cherchez quelque chose avait besoin
de quelque chose et là on entame la
conversation et puis bah non oui et puis
et puis mais vous venez régulièrement je
faisais remarquer je vous ai repéré
vouloir donner de tendances et capable
c'est mieux parce que c'est une
catastrophe
moi je risquerais de perdre mon emploi
pour elle et je lui ferais pas payer
certains articles annoncés petite
toilette
avec alex us orthez
tu sais que je vais mettre ça sur messi
pas les menacer plus c'est une super
technique soit meilleure amie qui
travaillait dans un supermarché on
embrasse seb je t'embrasse je t'aime je
n'avais rien à [ __ ] que j'embrassais
la bonne technique c'est de mettre des
rollers voilà vous savez les
[Musique]
fermes étaient des rouleurs vous prenez
la dame sur votre dos quand vous la
connaissez pas bah non mais vous les
proposer enfin un peu de folie dans la
vire et vous fait rêver qu'elle a voulu
ses nus
parler de stupéfiants
j'étais stressée mais d'assez
extraordinaire d'accord bas n'hésitez
pas de
nom pas du tout je mets mais c'est tout
à fait légal c'est une jour elle m'a dit
bien sûr vous dirai quelle marque pas ce
que je vois là je viens ça vous
intéresse vous l'investir site peut-être
déjà fait
aussi bien
pour les plans alambiqué ou la gemme et
noya bhl moi je pense que d'abord
premier premièrement eye contact hays
content mais je l'a atteint
donc je la regarde après je fais de
l'humour voilà alors ça va non mais je
les regarde je souris et je suis je
m'approche d'elle et je le dis vous
plaisez à l'esport mois moi ce que je
ferai ce que je ferai vous ramenez le
faire chez vous moi je vais vous dire
mais la technique dans le supermarché
c'est très simple prenez un ou deux
artistes un peu drôle et vous lui mettez
donc son caddie et vous dit à la meuf
pensé que ça pouvait faire plaisir à pas
mal sa série ça rigole
je sais pas tu prends les aubergines
et ses fils
j'avais une technique à l'époque je
draguais ouais j'ai arrêté plus de
nombreuses années oui c'est vrai quand
je branche et les meufs j'allais dans un
resto et je repérais par exemple une
meuf de muffin table et je leur envoyais
le plat le plus pourri de la carte c'est
à dire genre des trucs dégueulasses lors
du poulpe est arrivé au truc tout ça
fran ais genre et non système c'est à
dire que la salorge envoyés et georges
prenait une coupe comme ça je tenais
et les gens font leur cinéma
ça n'a jamais marché et voilà que ça me
coûtait 1 place et la deuxième le coach
en tout cas pour l'instant on n'est pas
au top syrine j'ai grave problème au
niveau de mon style vestimentaire toi on
dit que je ressemble à r t'aurais pas
des conseils signé guillaume genton
non non non ça c'est vraiment quelqu'un
qui ment vois ça j'ai des problèmes au
niveau de mon style vestimentaire oui
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire quand tu sais
pas comment tablier rouge habiller son
petit ami simple d'accord jean t-shirt
blanc d'accord jean et veste lestée war
bay ce double accord weis 2 ont trop de
bombers sont en a marre des bombers ce
parce que généralement ça va pas à
toutes les morphologies donc un mec qui
met un bon beurre ce qu'il est rapide de
base ça va être ignoble donc arrêtez les
bombers commencent à mettre des vestes
petite veste en jean des choses plutôt
sympa comme ça vraiment fait attention
mais la simplicité c'est le plus
important quand vous savez pas comment
vous habiller d'accord non c'est sympa
les conseillers de kelis a déconseillé
de 2021 dans en fait qu'ali je vous dire
la vérité vous donner des conseils on
prend pas de risque franchement
exactement ont peu de chances de tenir
c'est d'être au service comme guillaume
épargnants est très bon et des conseils
de 2021 moi je vous déconseille la
cerise de groupama les airs
c'est des conseils de 2021 moi je vous
donnais des conseils de 2023 déjà moche
ces nouveaux baux plus c'est moche plus
ses brassards et plein de couleurs vous
mélangez le vers le marron n'hésitez pas
attention pas plus de neuf couleurs
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
en soit à lui avancé aux vêtements
déchirés parce qu'un vêtement déchets
est un vêtement qui s'arrache bah oui
s'arrachent ses amis n'hésitez pas à
faire des clients et apporter des
vêtements des choses plus où isabelle
morini bosc alors entre non pas
guillaume les trucs à faire crever un
caméléon non mais moi ça serait plutôt
du style de kelly faut miser sur le
simple foulard steevy boulay mois ses
valeurs sûres et fois un truc affine
petit pantin comme vous vous voyez vous
n'êtes pas fait ça c'est pas ça qui va
signer pour moi je vous avais vraiment
meilleure musique manquer quand on
regarde la photo là vous avez vu comment
vous avez maigri
elle regardait retirer
regard
[Applaudissements]
merci on va s'arrêter là on va arrêter
la pièce
dernière question c'est cyril mezeix me
disent que je suis une grosse page je
n'arrive pas à trouver l'amour à cause
de ça comment je peux faire alors est ce
que maintenant la carte
bancaire sur la grille mais non non non
alors oui parce que est-ce que vous un
mec qui est vraiment une pince serré
méritoire c'est rédhibitoire
il se dit que si les six il est à moi si
c'est un hasard point de vue financier
c'est un avare en sentiments n'ont même
pas de moi qu'il est il et il est
généreux il est généreux et vous votre
vous êtes généreux je suis très gêné
robe beaucoup trop jeune vous êtes
généreux je te sens barre toi ouais
ouais ça va quand même 200 personnes
il a fait un tweet sa map la semaine
dernière mais la règle c'est que les
deux trois premiers rendez vous c'est le
mec qui paye et à poney même
réalisé des rôles aussi de garder oui
j'essaye ouais enfin nouveauté de toutes
mariées geneina au départ il l'était pas
il l'est devenu comme quoi il suffit d
fois d'être patiente sûre il suffit de
lui voler l'oseille
vous votre mac et les généreux moi j'ai
en tout cas très généreuse d'accord
merci en tout cas pas le savoir merci
mon mec il est génial ah ouais ses
généraux mais moi aussi ah ouais
irradiés on va tout est lié verniory
tueur l'argent et le sexe la généreuse
vous n'aimez pas manger vous n'aimez pas
faire dans quoi ils te paye
[Rires]
oui
alors c'est vrai qu'un mec airs mais ils
sont vraiment genre c'est une maladie à
mon avis c'est maladif royal arrive à ne
faisons pas bien ça ne pas laisser les
former à travailler là dessus oui c'est
quoi le plus beau cadeau vous ai déjà
une femme un gros cadeau un beau cadeau
que lui
franchement la maison bon non j'ai
offert d'un foie voilà j'ai fait une
folie a c'est que j'ai offert deux
paquets petit caca
caisse cool non mais franchement la plus
belle chose qui ne s'est même pas non
non j'ai une bague non mais sinon maison
mais
katia castaldi quel est le plus beau
cadeau vous avez faite femme bout parce
que moi je fais jamais de cadeaux alors
plus beau cadeau une fois j'ai acheté un
lustre
si vous avez la lumière à tous les
étages à l'us avec un lustre mais un
lustre pour le mistral en ciel ou à
appréhender et non comme ça il faisait 4
mètres de haut je suis pas parti avec
après quand j'ai quitté la personne
c'est dommage d'ailleurs et j'ai aussi
acquis face à tapha la vie je ne dirais
pas me dire que la vie à une voiture
aussi une voiture
non pas du tout mais j'ai jamais offert
une voiture on va faire quoi vous alors
mais moi je sais pas j'ai pas des ddd
des chaussettes
même classement n'ont pas autre chose
rarement des cadeaux
très généreux bah oui c'est vrai mais je
refais pas des cadeaux pour les
anniversaires de l'achat des cadeaux
comme ça fait ça pour les anniversaires
cherchera pas voilà par les adversaires
aiment pas vraiment le sentiment qu'on
vous forcent la main vous aimez le voilà
exactement benhabib vous qu'elle est
plus beau cadeau que vous avez fait
patoche
non non non non une très belle montre
c'est avec mon papa ma maman et lui ont
offert une très très belle montre j'en
rêvais depuis que j'avais 20 ans et je
les ai eus pour mai aux 45 ans c'est
beau et vous c'est quoi le plus beau
cadeau que vous ayez pris à partie la
voir alors qu'elle était dans un pays
étranger je suis parti d'avoir sans la
prévenir un message qu'on l'aurait
surpris
[Applaudissements]
mais chantal agitée
non mais non mais une thalassémie qui
m'a fait une surprise je combats c'est
ça le truc ah ouais c'est une bonne
thalassa quand ta meuf ou ton mec tu
fais une surprise qu'à l'autre bout du
monde et coutu et parfois ça peut
devenir une très grosse dallas
c'est sûr c'est sûr franchement c'est
une grosse grosse postale à moi ça m'est
arrivé un jour ça vous plaira j'étais au
club med ya une meuf à la voulu me faire
une surprise avec une autre bague aller
sous l'eau
je suis aller sous l'eau sur la tête de
ma mère c'est après mais c'est vrai j'y
vais pas parler de toutes les marques en
juniors mais parce qu'en fait
j'expliquerai tu étais pas vraiment but
était paru si
c'est encore 10 à 20